Nikki Haley the former ambassador to the
U.N former governor of South Carolina
current presidential candidate
sent a memo
to wealthy Republican donors basically
begging them for money
by trashing
both Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump
here's some of what the memo says here's
what the memo says about Trump
it's increasingly clear that Trump's
candidacy is more consumed by the
Grievances of the past and the promise
of more drama in the future rather than
a forward-looking vision for the
American people
no argument there like Nikki Haley your
campaign you hit the nail on the head
no critiques beautifully executed